i speak quite candidly and openly about
domestic abuse and domestic violence
particularly against women as well this
a subject the home secretary cares about
visiting a london pharmacy today to
promote the ask annie scheme annie's a
code word victims can use to ask for
help a lifeline for at least a hundred
women over the past year it is but the
tip of the iceberg
two women a week are killed as a result
of domestic violence last year rape
prosecutions were the lowest on record
is there a free pass to abuse women in
this country no way absolutely not it is
a fact that prosecution rates are
appallingly low we have the rape review
which actually was pretty harrowing
reading and pretty harrowing work in
march it's going to be the anniversary
of sarah everard's tragic murder
could you honestly look her parents in
the eye now and say to them that
anything has materially changed
since this time last year sarah
everard's murder was i'm really sorry to
say this but it just became such a a
significant moment and a tipping point
actually
around violence against women and girls
when you look at we have a strategy of
org strategy we will now have a lead
chief constable a lead figure in
policing working across all police
forces to have consistency around
violence against women and girls um
domestic abuse that's that's maggie
could make it a national priority though
no but it is it's absolutely some forces
it is some force it is not consistent
that's the point that is absolutely the
point about maggie blair's role and the
way in which we are driving this through
policing
we are done with the inconsistencies
inconsistencies that were amplified in
the pandemic charities struggling to
keep victims safe desperate for more
money our refuge bed spaces were filled
there were no spaces available
the referral and helplines were hearing
from people about the kind of abuse that
was was happening we were noticing their
difficulty in actually
finding the space to make a full phone
call so there were snatches of
conversations women were prisoners in in
quite coercive situations that's why
there was a big spike in cases right it
was a traumatic time i mean there's no
doubt locked down so hard for so many
people for so many reasons it perhaps
explains why the public are so angry
about the alleged party rule breaking in
number 10.
you've yet to publicly support the prime
minister are you
judgment until the su grey report comes
out rather like your colleague rishi
sunak no on the contrary i have publicly
supported the prime minister and
actually you're speaking to the home
secretary who spends all my time day in
day out you know supporting the prime
minister do you worry as home secretary
that if the police look that like
they're not going to investigate it that
it will undermine public confidence in
the police because they think that if
you're powerful and you run the country
that you're above the law no absolutely
not there were law enforcement processes
that took place at the time obviously
restrictions et cetera et cetera
retrospectively applying it you know at
a time when there's an investigation
taking place you know judgments will be
made about that if it turns out that he
does have to go
and i know you don't want that to happen
but presumably you would maybe have a
tilt at the top job i just don't think
it's relevant to be discussing you know
personalities right now at all we're
focused on doing the job that's not
ruling out but thank you very much home
secretary
for now trying to get on with the job in
hand as her boss buys time but the
business of government hard when the
leaders in free fall bathrigby sky news